[Music]
today I'm going to talk about some of
the research that we're going to do that
food that I've been working on called
the statistics of dirty data it's
basically a long story short we've been
looking at using statistical tools and
reconciling that with traditional
database guarantees of integrity
currency privacy things that were
generally logical constraints in the
past and I'm sort of gonna start off
with some of the theory and then talk
about how we're actually building those
into practical systems so many of you in
this room our familiar with data science
is obviously the data science track many
of you if you pulled out your business
card would have data scientist as your
job role under your name so there was an
article in the Harvard Business Review a
few years ago about the data scientist
being the sexiest job of the 21st
century now I don't know if I trust
Harvard Business Review for knowing what
sexy and what's not but there was
actually something really interesting in
this article that I really liked that
the data scientists roll is not purely
just statistical but it is to coax
treasure out of messy unstructured data
this is pretty much what is hard about
data science data science in some sense
of the confluence of computation and
data how do we use our programming to
basically get our data into a shape that
we can analyze that's basically the gist
of how what makes data science hard and
how data scientists operate in the real
world and if you guys don't know this
already
at least that this idea of structuring
unstructured data is one of the most hot
topics in academia right now if I was to
look at the top database conference
sigmod vldb and i CDE
since 2012 there been 204 papers on data
cleaning schema transformation data
integration data linkage all under these
different names but roughly speaking
dealing with dirty and unstructured data
and there's an entire industry that has
grown out of academia just on this do
companies like trifecta Data Kaymer and
so on so this is a really hot and
growing field right and in some sense
the reason that it's a hot and growing
field is the database community believes
that it has a unique perspective on data
cleaning while many people think about
data cleaning as this ad hoc interactive
unstructured process
that is kind of your freestyling and
improvising as things happen the
database community actually has a very
precise definition of data cleaning
believe it or not right basically the
way that the database community thinks
about dirty data is I have a table that
has a well defined schema I have a set
of integrity constraints on this table
and data cleaning is just the process of
contains constraint satisfaction for a
table that violates those integrity
constraints as a concrete example
suppose I have an accountant billing
table right where I have employee name
role and salary I have an integrity
constraints such as no manager can earn
less than an employee
now if there is a violation of this
constraint that's called dirty data and
the process of satisfying this
constraint is called data cleaning this
is what the database community does this
is the mental model when you talk about
data cleaning in a database conference
this is how people think right and what
the database community has gotten really
good at is translating that English
statement no manager can earn less than
an employee turning that into some sort
of a logical predicate turning that in a
sequel something that can be executed
very efficiently to enumerate all of
those tuples that participate in a
violation now the hard part is once you
find these violations what do you do
right you could make an employee a
manager you could set her salary higher
or lower right many different choices
that's what makes data cleaning hard so
I argued this this model is in some
sense stuck in the 1980s this model is
stuck in an era when the primary use
case of data cleaning and data integrity
and integrity constraints was accounts
and Billings transactions and things
like that
but nowadays we interact with data in a
fundamentally different way data is in
some sense not data in and of itself is
not the product we're often using it to
facilitate predictive models in the
future analytics visualizations in some
sense we're programming with the data
it's not that the data is the end
product right and that's basically the
premise of the work that we've been
we've been looking at over the last five
years at UC Berkeley basically saying
that how do we revisit this idea of data
cleaning the database community has a
very strict notion of what data cleaning
is and what it isn't
how do we revisit it in the era of these
kinds of new statistical analysis in
some sense everything we're doing is an
aggregate every single data point isn't
as important as it was before and
perhaps there are new ways of
approaching problems new analyses that
we can bring to bear on these problems
so the TLDR of this talk is that the
formalism of the old times is good we
should be thinking about data cleaning
formally we shouldn't be thinking about
this as an ad hoc process but the theory
needs updating we have lots of new
machinery and statistical analysis let's
see how we can bring this in there so
I'm going to talk about two works the
first work is how do we link the idea of
data over a pair of statistical analysis
in some sense build a statistical theory
about data repair the second piece of
this is how do we use that theory to
actually build practical systems that
can help you clean data more efficiently
and I'm gonna end with sort of what I
speculate these things are gonna go in
the future so let's start off with a
really concrete motivating example this
is an example that almost every data
scientist would immediately associate
with suppose I have a database such as a
list of publications right something
like Microsoft academic search or DB LP
one of your favorite academic academic
repositories for each one of these
authors there's a profile page where you
can pull out their fields that they're
been publishing in and their total
number of publications right so my
advisor is Michael Franklin and when I
pulled up this profile there's
immediately reason to doubt it he was
listed as a database person but he was
also arrested as a form of ecology for
the professor now there's clearly
something wrong here right we obviously
know that there were probably two
Michael Franklin's and the names are
some sort of a resolution problem
between these things so how do we trust
these counts so that was actually the
first two weeks of my PhD was we took
this data set and I went through all
thirteen hundred and fifty records by
hand and I actually validated was this
something that the real Michael Franklin
wrote was as something that the fake
Michael Franklin wrote I actually went
through each one of these publications
by hand and turns out the dirty count is
very different from the clean count
right what happens is there were not
only misattributions there were also
things like duplications and things that
were not quite publications things that
were adjourned things were there were
double counted in journal submissions
things that were double counted and
proceedings things were met were double
counted as posters and so on
right so the counts are very different
but there's one insight here suppose we
were interested in an analysis objective
suppose we were interested in the
analysis objective of just ranking these
authors did I need to clean everything
and the problem with the existing theory
on data cleaning was the answer would be
yes when you have a theory of integrity
constraints that is based on logic you
only deal with yes or no questions a
database is either consistent or
inconsistent any query on an
inconsistent database is potentially
inconsistent so there is no degrees of
accuracy so the key problem in data
cleaning that we realized is that there
was no notion of repair accuracy
trade-off like this is this is the piece
here and we needed an assault so we
started with a project called sample and
clean and here's the citation if you
were if you're interested in looking up
the paper that started off with a very
simple kind of problem setting you start
off with the sequel aggregate query so
it's such as select count from all the
publications grouped by the author I
have a big dirty database as a data
scientist you're only allowed to apply
whatever data cleaning technique you
have to a sample of this data so you're
allowed to devise all of your rules all
of your cleaning all of your
transformation only on a small sample of
this data now the question is how
accurately can you answer this query now
you might think that this is a
straightforward sampling statistics
problem right but the basic problem is
that data cleaning actually changes the
statistics of the data and furthermore
dirtiness and corruption can also affect
sampling statistics for example if I
have duplicated records those duplicates
are more likely to show up in any random
sample that I have and in some sense I
don't know that those duplicates are
there because if I knew that they were
there I would have not had this problem
in the first place right so it creates
these chickens the chicken and egg
problems so long story short what ends
up happening is for most of these sequel
aggregates what kind of breaks is the
sampling probabilities and in some sense
the solution method that we had to this
problem is coming up with adjustments
figuring out how to do the right book
keeping for certain classes of data
errors and certain classes of data
cleaning operations to make sure that
these sampling statistics can have
cancel out with each other and that's
basically what we did this is kind of a
gross simplification of the paper but
the basic idea is you can kind of down
wait whatever result you have by the the
duplication probability and estimated
duplication probability and also like
whether it is likely whether it is
likely relevant to your query and
irrelevant to your query and there's a
lot of details in our paper and how we
can do that and there are a lot of
tricky proofs but the point is that what
this allows us to do is it allows us to
take a sample of data transform the
sample to pretend as if we're sampling
from a hypothetical clean dataset
re-weighting probabilities readjusting
all the way it's dealing with the
problems and now we get a kind of
fictitious sample that we can query with
any sequel aggregate query there are a
lot of other interesting things that we
can do to reduce the variance we can
look at how much does the data cleaning
change a certain sample of data how much
does it change a sequel query what kinds
of sequel queries are more sensitive and
less sensitive there's a lot of theory
we can build on it just from the simple
problem setting starting off with a
sequel query a sample of clean data and
thinking about how those effect answers
so this was sort of the the genesis of
the results that we started thinking
about okay if this simple problem
setting the simple tie between data
cleaning and sampling statistics even
though it was like a very simplified
model started giving us a lot of
theoretical insights for example in this
Microsoft academic search result we
realized given the distribution of data
for these three authors we could get
away with cleaning only 100 records
before with 85 percent probability over
all possible worlds of those hundred
records cleaned we'd basically get the
right answer right this was actually
really this is really interesting to us
so in many tasks it actually suffices to
clean a very small amount of data a
small amount of good data goes a long
way so we actually built this into a
real system and I also give you the
links to all the github pages and my
website later where you could basically
write as you could write a proof you
could write a data cleaning program
programmatically in our domain-specific
language using crowdsourcing using
machine learning whatever you wanted as
long as it sort of conform to our api's
we would do all the bookkeeping behind
the hood to basically estimate and
correct for these changes in probability
then we integrated it into this
stack so this was a project called
wisteria there's a paper and then
there's a link probably on my website at
the end to github pages so I just want
to talk about what are the salient
pieces here so we we took this work this
was a starting point that was about five
years ago basically there are three
pieces first there's some some notion of
uncertainty we need to think about the
data scientist as living in an uncertain
world they don't they get incomplete
information about the data that they're
working with they're either working with
a sample maybe it's a noisy view of data
maybe they're seeing dirty data so the
devising rules they're devising
transformations based on some noisy view
of the world then there's a language
data cleaning should almost never be in
a current complete language you
shouldn't be thinking about data
cleaning is happening in an arbitrary as
an arbitrary C program there are
well-defined transformations
well-defined data types and well-defined
invariants that need to be satisfied
that is kind of the second piece here
the third piece was you have some sort
of a quantity that you're trying to
estimate data cleaning is a means to an
end it is not that the data is a product
anymore you're trying to train a model
estimate an aggregate try to rank
something in a list right so these were
the three pieces that we were able to
extend several times over the last few
years
for example now what happens if we want
to say how do we most efficiently clean
data for machine learning tasks suppose
I have trained a model and I have a list
of missed predictions I don't know why
this model is going wrong is it data
error is it model error is it something
else as a sampling error do I just need
more data
do I need to clean some data do I need
to collect new labels right this was the
basic question that we have we took
exactly the same machinery a sample
cleaned and we put it into a system
called active clean where we figured out
how to prioritize which records to clean
and how to actually update the analysis
after cleaning this turned out to be
actually kind of a subtle problem talk
to me offline if you're interested in
this but long story short we are
actually able to apply this to a lot of
interesting real problems for example
there's a there's a data set published
by pro-public I don't believe it's
online anymore but it was called the
dollars for doctors data set it had
250,000 records of medical contributions
that were manually labeled as suspicious
or not for for fraudulent contributions
and things like that the problem is that
there were interesting entity resolution
problems in drug names and company names
for example Pfizer as Pfizer Inc
all sorts of other variants of the same
name they have subsidiaries that all
need to be linked together so now the
question is you how much budget you if
you have a budget of looking at say
1,000 of these entities instead of all
of the records how how do you most
efficiently place that budget and we
basically showed that compared to other
techniques this technique which are
called active clean performed the best
and could actually get very close to the
CRU model accuracy with just a little
bit of good data again same thing as
sample clean a little bit of good data
with probably the proper estimation
structure properly weighting proper
proper prioritization can actually get
you a long way and basically there's
also bound for it too
we can basically show that theoretically
this is also justified as well so there
are there a whole bunch of other
applications and there's kind of kind of
breeze through it but you can change
replace the sampling with randomization
suppose instead of seeing a sample of
data the analyst can only see a private
view of the data set that means like
some sort of a randomized view of the
data set again we can do very similar
analysis and say that on a private view
the data said these are the kinds of
operations you can do these are kind of
queries you can answer and so on
interestingly enough the same theory has
applications and streaming systems it
has ways that you can actually
approximately update views of the data
set suppose I have a big database of
orders and I have analyst views and
analyst visualizations of just the users
from the USA just users with orders
about $300 just users from China and
anytime that this base data has changed
you're gonna have to propagate those
updates turns out you can pose it as a
very similar data cleaning problem where
staleness is the type of data error and
you can actually figure out ways to
efficiently sample and prioritize your
attention in these systems so that you
can get bound herbal query results on
these views but not have to spend the
full cost again linking the traditional
notion of logical consistency to
statistical and analytics because you
know we're doing some sort of aggregate
of the downstream
I'm gonna kind of skip through this in
the interest of time just just so I can
get to the exciting stuff so that was
the theory of what we kind of proposed
before right we wanted to be able to
link data repair some sort of
statistical notion that doesn't help you
guys because in some sense that's a
really academic model of the world right
it's sort of thinking about data
cleaning in the abstract not really
telling you how to clean your data but
what cleaning is the next step that
we've been looking at is looking at the
intersection of data cleaning and
program synthesis how can we leverage
new tools in AI to more efficiently
synthesize solutions to data clearing
problems so let's take an example of
example that I've been working on that I
worked on a few years ago so we sent out
a whole bunch of iPads to rural Uganda
in collaboration with the USAID to
collect a lot of data on their
reproductive health programs so they run
these training camps in these villages
to to train young mothers on on best
neonatal practices and so on right so
the key problem here is that when the
data came back to Berkeley it was
totally not in the form that we could
analyze it there was a mix of in the age
column you can see that there's a mix of
numerical data and categorical data as
well right it's like it's like this was
partially collected on digital iPads it
was partially collected on paper forms
when it came back we hired undergrad
interns to code this up this is kind of
a familiar problem right in you know all
fairness all the information we need is
there in this column but the problem is
is just not in the format that we need
to analyze it and I see this as kind of
symptomatic of what goes wrong in
typical data cleaning problems it's not
that the data is completely missing it's
just that the data acquisition and data
curation process is divorced from the
analysis that you're doing right because
if the undergrads were also in charge of
analyzing the data they absolutely would
not have typed in 20 when they were
entering in the ages they would have
known to convert that into a number
right now what this basically means is
something really troubling for people
like me who live in the database world
if I was to write say a Python program
in our program to process this day
it would get really long I would
basically have to enumerate all of these
small special cases every single place
where something was done in a unique way
I'd have to write that as one new line
in my program one new transformation
rule and all the scalability that we've
been proposing in the database community
is pointless if your program is on the
order of dear data right we can scale
concise programs we can't scale a
program that's the same length of your
data right that's kind of that's kind of
hard so this is what we really found how
did that happened is like the math
section of your programming of your code
was really small but the data cleaning
section was huge because it'll just have
all of these transformation rules so
there has to be a better way there has
to be some way to avoiding your program
from encoding these literals that are
better representing these errors but
then this goes back to the old data base
perspective right in the old data base
perspective when you think about things
in terms of integrity constraints no
manager can earn less than an employee
you're saying something really deep here
you're really saying I want my data set
to satisfy these properties right can we
leverage this idea of integrity
constraints to basically come up with a
new programming model for data cleaning
that's kind of our next project that
we've been looking at what I want to be
able to do in a data set like this is to
be able to say I want this age to be a
floating-point number
I want this property to be satisfied
these are the kinds of operations you're
allowed to do you're allowed to delete
tokens you're a lot of translate text
into numbers I'm gonna put in a question
mark because I don't care about what the
literal you are you've you figure out
how to do that you put both these pieces
the invariant and the language into an
optimizer the optimizer turns away I
don't care how much money or how much to
teach your burn on this but then
generate the program for me now from a
human's perspective you only have to
care about specifying the template and
specifying the invariant you don't have
to care about how the optimizer is
choosing to execute how the optimizer is
choosing to group functions together to
make these more efficient how the
optimizer is choosing to implement these
functions underneath the hood this is
ultimately what we want and to get it
there we realize that actually something
has changed in the last few years
data cleaning is actually in this the
way that I presented is an instance of
planning as you see an AI and machine
learning today basically you have a
language of transformations you have
some notion of data quality of some sort
of a reward some sort of a quality the
number of invariant violations that you
have and your output is a composite
transformation that means a composition
of these things a sequence of these
transformations if you will that
optimizes their reward cumulatively over
the entire dataset and the cool part is
that we've actually gotten the tools
more tools in recent years to solve this
than we've had in the past we have first
a lot more compute we can just we can
paralyze and scale these things up and
second we've gotten a lot more
understanding on how to actually address
these high branching factor search
problems so our idea was that something
like this has definitely been thought of
before but it may have been dismissed
ten years ago as an impractical solution
to something like data cleaning or data
transformation can we revisit this
problem with the new tools that AI has
to offer and that's basically our system
it's kind of cute Lee known as alpha
clean basically it has a three layer
stack at the top there's an execution
engine that basically takes in a probe
that that takes a that spits out a
logical program and illiterate and
generalizes literals in your in your
system at the bottom there's a
specification layer where the human only
specifies a library basically says these
are the functions you're allowed to use
specifies a quality function what
defines clean and then there's some sort
of things that handles hints on data
types and things like that then there's
a narrow waist in the middle this
optimizer this AI search algorithm that
basically searches for the best program
that satisfies these invariants the best
search is over the set of
transformations and gets you to your
invariant solution so how does this look
like in practice let's kind of get get a
concret example suppose I have this data
set I can load this into a panda's data
frame I load this as a standard CSV I
can provide things like patterns I can
say that I want my age to be a
floating-point number between 18 and 100
I want all the responses from these
participants to be alphanumeric I want
all the parishes the parish names where
they collected this data to be in some
code book of dictionary of allowed
parishes
then I can specify multi-column
constraints I can say that I want a
functional dependency between parish and
day that means I want there to be a map
that means that every parish is
associated uniquely with a single day
when data was collected I can also
specify more complicated logical checks
for example I want to make sure that
nobody under the age of 22 is listed to
having more than five children I can
also put in soft constraints things like
I expect age and children to be
correlated
I expect that the data kind of looks
like the previous year's model I combine
all of these pieces together into a
quality function our system compiles us
down into a single single quantitative
metric of per record a score of how many
constraints that's violating then then
the question is how do we design the
language and we found out that actually
most data cleaning fits into a pretty
concise language of transformations
here's a subset of the things that we do
right for example find find and replace
this is a surprisingly powerful
primitive for given attribute find one
one attribute value and replace it with
another attribute value clip that means
look at a numerical value and clip it
down to some sort of a threshold
filtering out certain tokens removing
certain weird tokens like things like
sub strings from an attribute value and
reg X's right these are all very well
parameterize transformation things but
can actually capture in composition with
each other it can capture a huge set of
data cleaning programs so that basically
gives us the first two pieces right how
do we define a language how do we define
a quality function and now the cool part
is searching over this is basically a
tree search we basically start off with
a no op and we start sequencing these
things together right we start off with
a no op then we try out a composition
with the first transformation the second
transformation the third transformation
and again we kind of recurse we just
keep on going forward now as you can
imagine this growth this search space
grows exponentially but there are parts
of this problem that we can actually
exploit typical errors are localized
they often effect only small subsets of
the data and typical errors are
systematic that means they're correlated
with certain attribute types and
basically what this means is that we can
actually be very
the search algorithm and we found that
empirically very greedy search
strategies work really well and the
other part that we that made this
possible was we took a leaf out of the
google play book on alphago what we can
do is we can clean data in small blocks
so we can spend our expensive search on
a few small blocks of data and start
learning what types of transformations
are relevant to this data set what
attributes tend to be dirty
what literals tend to be inside these
transformations and as we keep on going
what this ends up doing is learning a
scoring function if those of you guys
are familiar with reinforcement learning
this is actually just a cue function but
what we can do is we can start
anticipating what types of
transformations there are and encoding
domain-specific feature is a shion's to
basically make this the search algorithm
more and more powerful like we can take
these transformations use our NLP
techniques to know like what what what
are likely errors what are likely
correlations that we should be
exploiting so in terms of empirical
results we've could be benchmark this
system against a lot of existing a lot
of existing tools some of them don't
have real names because we don't we
don't want to call out commercial tools
and so on but for example we looked at a
data set of news articles these were
news articles about terrorist incidents
since the 1970s and these articles often
had duplicates because they were
multiple news articles referred to the
same incident they had they had multiple
discrepancies and like the dates that
they happened in they had discredited
had admit lots of missing values and so
on so we came up with the entity
matching tool which will be unnamed so a
tool that does deduplication of data and
does large-scale deduplication a tool
from MIT that does outlier detection
distant America liar detection and then
a classical database integrity
constraint satisfaction algorithm s was
used back in the day not your IBM
systems and so on so now if we took
these three things eeehm only D boost
and chase and combine them together
naively we're gonna get some precision
and recall and we're obviously going to
get the best precision and recall of all
of them because we tuned these really
well
but the cool part is alpha clean AC plus
l alpha clean and this learning learned
heuristic acts
does better than the combined algorithm
fix because what we can do is we can
actually turn all of those objectives
into a single quality function and
optimize jointly over them rather than
treating them as individual systems
because we've put this in this AI
planning framework where we can
basically optimize over all of them
simultaneously now obviously that's one
of the cost of a lot more compute it
requires eight times more compute than
the competitors fair enough but that's
kind of where the research has to go we
believe that there are interesting
opportunities as thinking about these
problems as combined problems thinking
about them as program synthesis problems
rather than building specialized systems
similarly the some of the problems had
the benefits are seen in problems like
schema integration suppose I have to do
two steps I have to integrate a schema
that means I have two data sets which
there's their columns aligned but they
align in some weird way and I don't know
what that is I first have to join the
columns and then I have to merge the
data and deal with any hers again you
could do these two things separately you
can do schema integration and your data
cleaning in two different in two
different passes but doing them as a
combined operation has benefits because
it optimizes these things jointly
sometimes there's going to be an order
of operations here so they sort of move
into here so the last result that I'd
kind of like to sort of highlight over
here is there's something really
interesting going on here right I'll
quickly and we believe changes the way
that you think about data cleaning
because it's talking about data cleaning
as a search over the space of data
cleaning programs rather than searching
over the space of data data edits to a
certain database right and and the cool
part about this is actually one of our
insights recent insights was this means
that everything we know about machine
learning actually starts applying to
data cleaning there is a notion of
overfitting under fitting in data
cleaning as well right some
transformations that are overly specific
may not generalize to new data they're
just not going to be relevant they won't
apply to any new data that comes in
right if it's extremely specific
transformations that are too general
might have unwanted side effects on your
data and we can actually exactly
characterize that in the same way that
we have statistical learning theory to
characterize the
that prediction rules may over fit under
fit and generalize we can talk about
data cleaning problem programs
overfitting under fitting and
generalizing turns out we can get a
really elegant formula that says that
this is roughly proportional to
something called the sensitivity which
is how sensitive is your data quality
function that means that one record was
to change how much would the change in
how many new violations would you create
times 1 over square root of the amount
of data which is your standard sampling
problem and roughly logarithmic in the
size of the true number of
transformations are searching over so if
you're searching over more
transformations you're more likely to
over fit if you are more sensitive
you're not likely to generalize if you
have more data it solves both problems
so it's kind of very similar in spirit
to the kinds of things that we're seeing
in machine learning but we can
characterize this for data cleaning if
we pose the data cleaning problem in
this way so that sort of ties up these
two pieces we add sample clean which is
linking data repair to statistical
analysis and alpha clean which is
applying these new AI machinery to talk
about data cleaning and the consequence
of kind of goes full circle we can
actually start analyzing the output
programs with alpha clean from a
statistical perspective as well building
up of rich theory that we've now
developed in machine learning and
bringing that over to the idea of data
transformation to me personally if we
start talking about data cleaning as
being 80 versus 20 in terms of the
amount of effort that you're putting
it's kind of a travesty that we don't
have a statistical theory to describe
data cleaning and this is kind of a
first step in that direction we should
be doing a lot more understanding how
these kinds of operations affect any
downstream processes that go so here are
some of the references my website is my
website is listed below and there are
links to code there's there's father
links to my github as well but we've
basically done a whole bunch of
different work and all of them kind of
have the same flavor we have we talked
about data cleaning before statistical
analysis I've done work on crowdsourcing
because data cleaning is often very
intimately linked to having humans come
in and verify and clean data and we've
also talked about how do we write to
approximate data bases which also has
the same kind of feel to it
and if there's one thing that I want you
to take away from this as data cleaning
is a statistical problem we should not
analyze these two problems in a divorced
way we should be analyzing data cleaning
and whatever analysis you're doing in a
joint way because this is where bugs
come from by treating these as two
distinct processes thank you we have
time for a couple of questions while we
get the next speaker set up yeah it
seemed a bit arbitrary that constraint I
have a feeling it was a hack yep
so what could you do to help people
right constraints good good yeah yeah
good great great questions so so the way
that I look at it is this is always the
problem with declarative programming in
general right it's a declarative until
it's not right you start having to
encode some imperative things inside
your declarative programs so what we
could what we are working on right now
is rather than having users write these
constraint specifically have the users
transform a few example records when
they have difficulty coming up with a
certain constraints show on a few
records actually manually modify this
and try to infer out what kind of
constraints are there what is the most
explainable constraint that they're
they're trying to enforce by their
modifications this is one solution the
wrong I think it's a really hard problem
and I think it's a it's a problem if
there was a good solution to it there
would be a good solution to synthesizing
sequel queries and be a good solution to
synthesizing data log queries this is
this is a huge problem it's like why do
we sometimes tell our Postgres optimizer
hints to do joins better it's exactly
the same problem it's like it should
work but it doesn't so yeah no it's a
great great question I was wondering if
you just quick clear quickly clarify one
of the aspects of what you're talking
about
you showed this black box optimizer yeah
and then you also show the users
specifying some transformation functions
is the optimizer generating
transformation functions or is the
youngster responsible for so the user
specifies templates that means
transformation functions and pre literal
if you will the the optimizer
automatically generates the space of
possible transformations with space of
possible sequences of transformations
and optimizes over that okay and then
the user says like I want this
transformation language I don't want
that trip yeah or they or the users
quality function prunes the space the
optimizer prunes the space using the
users quality function yeah what the
user is defining us clean
[Music]